♪ ♪
>> Judge Jeanine: BRAND-NEW
DETAILS ON THE POLITICAL
VIOLENCE A MAN WHO RAN DOWN AND
MURDERED A TEENAGER WITH THIS
TRUCK BELIEVING HE WAS A
REPUBLICAN EXTREMIST.
BRIAN THE WIND OF THE
NORTH DAKOTA HIGHWAY PATROL SAYS
THAT THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF THE
TEEN WAS REPUBLICAN EXTREMIST
AND BACK TO THE CASE SO FAR DO
NOT SUPPORT HIS CLAIMS THAT HE
AND TAYLOR ELLINGTON ARGUE ABOUT
POLITICS OR THAT THE TEENAGER
WAS FALLING FOR PEOPLE TO COME
AFTER THEM.
INVESTIGATION IS STILL ONGOING,
THE CASES PUTTING A SPOTLIGHT
AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF HEATED
POLITICAL RHETORIC.
SENATOR RAND PAUL WORKS IN A
VIOLENT CONSEQUENCES.
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN IS TO
REALIZE THAT HIS VILIFICATION OF
HIS OPPONENTS IS INFLAMING SOME
OF HIS SUPPORTERS TO VIOLENCE.
AS A VICTIM OF POLITICAL
VIOLENCE BOTH SIDES NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONSEQUENCES OF
HEATED RHETORIC.
BEFORE I GET INTO THE
CONSEQUENCE OF HEATED RHETORIC
JESSE IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
THERE SEEMS TO BE NOT A LOT OF
INFORMATION THE STATE'S AND
I COUNTY AND A CALLED OFFICE
SEVERAL TIMES RIGHT OF AN ACTION
ANSWERING THE PHONES.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN THE
STATE SPEAKS OUT ABOUT THE
MURDER AND SAYS THAT THE SUSPECT
IS ADMITTED THAT HIS ACTIONS
WERE MOTIVATED BY DISPUTE OVER
POLITICAL BELIEFS.
THERE'S NOT A LOT MORE THAT IS
OUT THERE.
WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS CASE?
>> THERE IS A LOT OUT THERE IT'S
A VERY SMALL TOWN AND THE
FUNERAL I BELIEVE IS TOMORROW OR
SUNDAY AND HE ARE BRINGING IN
SECURITY FOR THE FEDERAL BECAUSE
THEY FEEL LIKE THE ENTIRE MEDIA
HAS DESCENDED UPON THE STORY
ONLINE.
NOT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IN A
WHOLE PROTECT THEMSELVES IS VERY
TENDER AND FRAGILE TIME RIGHT
NOW IT HAS EVEN HAPPEN SO IF YOU
LIKE ONCE A FUNERAL IS OVER COME
OVER THIS GUY'S STORY DOESN'T
END.
WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY IF
YOU'RE IN A TRUCK I WAS A
TEENAGER THREATENING YOU WITH
THE PHONE AND JUST CREW IS
ANYONE THERE.
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT THE SKYPE
MADE UP THE REPUBLICAN EXTREMIST
THING, OR THE SKY SAID HEARING
SOURCES ARE SAYING ONE WORD TO
THE GUY, ONE WORD AND HE
SNAPPED.
LOOK AT A COUNTRY THAT'S
TEETERING RIGHT?
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT THE BEST
WE'VE EVER BEEN RIGHT NOW
FINANCIALLY PSYCHOLOGICALLY
COMING OFF OF: RAND PAUL GOT HIS
RIBS CRACKED HE GOT A BULLET IN
THE HEART.
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF MAJOR
VIOLENT ATTACKS AGAINST
HIGH-PROFILE REPUBLICANS,
HILLARY GOES UP AND SHE BRINGS
UP NAZISM TO DONALD TRUMP AND SO
ON THE HEELS OF JOE BIDEN SAYING
HALF THE COUNTRIES FASCIST.
SO PEOPLE NEED TO REALLY PUMP
THE BRAKES RIGHT NOW BECAUSE YOU
DO NOT WANT THIS TO GET WORSE.
>> ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IT SEEMS
IS THAT THE GUY WHO'S DOING THE
INVESTIGATION IF THAT'S HIS NAME
WAS BASICALLY SAME IS NO WAY OF
EXTREMISM, BUT THE EVIDENCE
COMES FROM THE DEFENDANT'S
MOUTH.
THE ACCUSED IS THE ONE SAYING
THAT HE WAS EXTREMIST THE VICTIM
THAT HE RAN OVER.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE
NOT CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT IS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY DON'T
WANT TO INSTIGATE OR CAUSE ANY
PROBLEM, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THE FACTS OF THE FACTS BUT IT
SEEMS THAT WHAT JESSE SAID THAT
WHEN A REPUBLICAN GETS SHOT AT A
BASEBALL GAME BY A
BERNIE SANDERS SUPPORTER BECAUSE
THAT REPUBLICAN IS A GUY PLAYING
HIS REPUBLICAN EVERYONE SAYS
LET'S ALL BE FRIENDS LET'S ALL
BE FRIENDS.
>> DON'T FORGET THAT THE PRESENT
WAS TO GET A STICKING THE FBI ON
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS WHO HAPPEN
TO BE RIGHT WING TO MYSTIC
TERRACE ARE THE BIGGEST THREATS
TO THE HOMELAND.
THAT'S COMING OUT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S MOUTH HE ALSO SAID
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
INVESTIGATE MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE NOT
HARBORING FAR RIGHT EXTREMIST
VIEWS.
SO THEY HAVE ALREADY PAINTED
HALF THE COUNTRY WITH A VERY
VIOLENT BRUSH JUST BECAUSE
SOMEONE BELIEVES HIM
INDIFFERENTLY MENU THIS WILL
HAVE THE RIGHT TO EXIST THIS OF
THE RIGHT TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPINIONS, THIS IS AN 18-YEAR-OLD
KID WITH THE RIGHT TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND GET A JOB AND HAVE A
FAMILY AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
PEOPLE DO 41-YEAR-OLD IF HE HAD
A POLITICAL DISAGREEMENT DOES
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO END THE
LIFE OF A KID I'M SURE
TECHNICALLY HE WAS AN ADULT, BUT
THIS IS WERE SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
THEY FEEL LIKE VIOLENCE IS
JUSTIFIED BECAUSE POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES ARE IN THEMSELVES
VIOLENCE THAT WORDS ARE VIOLENT
THAT IS WHERE WE ARE AND THAT IS
SO AND COULD BE DANGEROUS AND I
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE IF YOUR FRIENDS
AND FAMILY MEMBERS HAVE
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION IN TERMS
OF POLITICS REACH OUT TO THEM
THIS WEEKEND MAKE THINGS BETTER,
FIND COMMON GROUND.
[LAUGHS]
>> Judge Jeanine: THE TRUTH IS
THAT WE ARE ON EDGE THIS COUNTRY
IS ON EDGE.
WE'VE GOT A PRESIDENT AND PEOPLE
LIKE HILLARY CLINTON THERE
SAYING THAT WE ARE EXTREMISTS IN
OUR AND FASCISTS AND ALL THIS
OTHER STUFF I'M IN AT SOME POINT
IT'S GOT A STOP.
>> Tyrus: THE TRUTH IS IS THAT
CRIMINALS KNOW THAT.
AND THEY ARE EMBOLDENED AND THEY
DO THINGS AND THE COP IS WELL HE
WAS A REPUBLICAN EXTREMIST SO
DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS ERA ALL
THOUGHT HE WAS BLACK I THOUGHT
IT WAS A BLACK MAN TRIES TO GET
MY AND IT WAS A CERTAIN TIME
THAT STILL HAPPENS RIGHT?
AND IS ON NOW QUESTION MARKET IS
THE SAME THING.
HE SEES THE SAME TV THAT IF ON
ALL SLOPES HE PROBABLY DIDN'T
LIKE THE WAY THE KID LOOKED
MAYBE HE WASN'T PAYING ATTENTION
WHATEVER HE DID HE RAN HIM DOWN
AND WHEN THEY BROUGHT HIM IN
MADAM DID TO RIGHTS HE WAS IN
THE CAR AND CALLED MY MOM ON THE
YOUNG MEN PASSED AWAY WHILE HE
WAS REPUBLICAN EXTREMIST.
THAT CHANGE THE WHOLE THING
BECAUSE WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THIS YOUNG MAN.
WHEN I TALK ABOUT THE
COLD-BLOODED MURDER YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE JESSICA FLETCHER TO
SOLVE THIS ONE, BUT INSTEAD WE
ARE ARGUING OVER WHETHER THIS
WAS POLITICAL HATE CRIME
REGARDLESS OF WHAT IT WAS.
THIS MAN KILLED THIS YOUNG MAN
HE ENDED HIS LIFE.
WHATEVER HIS EXCUSE WAS WHEREVER
IT'S IRRELEVANT SHOULD BE OPEN
AND SHUT CASE, BUT THIS IS WHAT
THE MEDIA TALK ABOUT.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT WAS
COLD-BLOODED MURDER AND YET HE
IS STILL CHARGED WITH VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER IT IS NOT VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER HE TOOK HIS VEHICLE
AND USE IT AS A WEAPON TO KILL
SOMEBODY.
>> I HEARD YOU YESTERDAY TALKING
ABOUT THAT AND THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT.
ALL OF OUR PRAYERS GO OUT TO THE
DECEASED IN THE FAMILY IN THE
COMMUNITY IT'S VERY SMALL
COMMUNITY DEALING WITH THIS.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL THAT ALL
THESE FACTS COME OUT.
WHEN THEY FIND EVEN MORE
TOMORROW OR MONDAY OR TUESDAY ON
THE SHOW THE LAST THING IS WHAT
TROUBLES ME IS THIS PERSON
KILLED THE SNOWMAN THOUGHT THAT
SOMEHOW OR ANOTHER HIS ACTIONS
MIGHT BE PERCEIVED AS
DIFFERENTLY IF HE SAID IT WAS A
POLITICAL DISPUTE ULCER ON THE
STABLE OTHER VIEWS WHETHER THEY
AGREE OR DISAGREE WITH ANOTHER
EVERYONE IS ENTITLED TO THE
VIEWS WELLESLEY TO TAKE A STEP
BACK BECAUSE WE CAN ALL LIKE ONE
ANOTHER OR ARGUE WITH ONE
ANOTHER WE CAN DISAGREE WITH ONE
ANOTHER, WE COULD BE WRONG, WE
COULD BE RIGHT WE CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE TO ENGAGE IN VIOLENCE
AND FOR THIS MAN TO BELIEVE THAT
HE COULD FIND SOME JUSTIFICATION
ON SOME MITIGATION AND HIS
PENALTY SEEN THAT THIS
18-YEAR-OLD WAS A MAGA A
REPUBLICAN WE'VE DISSENTED TO A
VERY, LOW PLACE AND HOPE WE CAN
ALL FIGURE OUT AS MUCH AS WE MAY
DIFFER OR WE AGREE WITH THE LOOK
YOURSELVES UP A BIT SO MY
PRAYERS GO OUT TO HIS COMMUNIT